okay so welcome to today's rendering
lecture this is going to be unit 4 we
will have two parts in it so one the
first part will be spatial acceleration
structures and the next part will be
tone mapping I will hold to the next
three lectures so this one ends two more
and then color it takes over again so
special acceleration structures so we
are we the rendering pipeline as it was
shown in the first lecture so we start
with a 3d scene perform some kind of
light simulation generate image out of
it that's going to be displayed so
spatial acceleration structures are
central to the light simulation because
the increased efficiency of ray shooting
so as you heard last time ray based
methodologies so from geometric optics
are mainly employed to enable
photorealistic rendering and in this
work you have to shoot a lot of rays so
usually in the order of million to
billion and if you can cut down the
computational cost of this procedure
then you will gain significant speed ups
so to summarize so generally the
multicolor method uses ray shooting to
sample the integrand of the rendering
equation which on the last time so
usually you have to compute the closest
intersection with the scene so this is
equivalent to computing the local
visibility so how far does it rate
travel through the scene before it hits
its first object and this is usually
very expensive for a large amount of
scene objects because if you start with
one ray and you want to check does it
intersect any of my scenes in triangles
then if you have millions of triangles
than each ray has to check
Dominion of triangles which ones the
first that they intersect if you have
millions of rays you see that this is
quadratic explosion and you will not
converge in any reasonable time to a
high quality image so the naive approach
would be just to determine the
intersection with each object so the
object could not be usually triangles
can also be nonlinear surface patches or
whatever you want to use so if you just
go through all the objects one after the
other and check which one is the closest
you have to go through all the object to
it's a linear approach so the
complexities or in a better approach
would be to reorganize all the objects
in your scene say the triangles in some
kind of spatial hierarchy so they don't
know that say in the left half of this
room is are these triangles in the right
half of these triangles and then if I
have a ray that I know that it only
travels through one half of the room
then I can immediately discard half of
the triangles in my scene and don't need
to intersect against them so these are
this approach I mean it's a bit more
sophisticated than that leads them to a
sub linear complexity usually it gets
close to logarithmic so I mean this is a
very old topic so this popped up very
soon when ray tracing was used so there
are many methodologies that were looked
into and two main techniques say are
considered the state of the art so one
are KD trees and the other are bounding
volume hierarchies so a KD tree sap
divides the space itself so your scene
is situated in a surrounding space three
dimension
and you then um cut this space into
pieces as can be seen in this example on
the right hand side here the space in
which the observe objects reside is just
a square and each object is just a point
and as you see with recursive
subdivision of the space you group the
objects together in our spatially local
volumes so and if you the right side
gives you the subdivision of the space
itself and where the objects line those
but each split of the space can be seen
as as a construction of a binary tree so
you start off have the root node which
is the whole space then you try to find
some kind of good cut through the space
so that approximately half of the
objects are in one half and half of the
objects on the other so it doesn't make
sense to start off with the whole volume
and then separate a very small part from
it because every ray has to start its
traversal of the tree at the root node
and then it has the decision am I in the
peak volume or do I have to check the
small volume too if you have a lot of
small volumes then this is inefficient
again so what you want to do is to place
or to get the criteria that you are not
going to have to intersect a lot of
triangles as far up in the three years
possible so in this example the first
cut the vertical cut through the whole
space subdivides the objects
approximately in half so that half of
the objects are left of the cut half of
the objects are right of the cut in 3d
this would be a cut plane through the
volume but it's the same procedure
and then you recursively subdivide the
depart so the two sub volumes that you
generated with the first cut and also
try again to have half of the objects
there half of the objects there and you
continue with this procedure until you
have one object per volume I mean of
course you can also terminate earlier so
if you are okay with having 100
triangles in each leaf node of the tree
then you have to check through all these
100 triangles if you enter the sub space
but the the main advantage you gain with
this is that if you have some way
through this volume then you can do very
quick checks against the subspaces so
you know that all the subspace here are
rectangles in a volume they would be
boxes and you can do very quick
intersection tests against boxes and if
the if you know that you are not going
to intersect the box which is one test
but there are thousands of triangles in
this box then you can immediately
discard all these triangles for your
real intersection test so you only have
to check the triangle intersections in
those boxes that you checked beforehand
that you intersect and you can imagine
that if you have huge areas that you
don't intersect you gain a lot of speed
because you don't to unnecessary work so
kitty trees subdivide the space and then
you have to attend the subproblems the
objects lie another approach bounding
volume hierarchies
they are you group the objects together
so you take you start with the triangles
and then you say I put closed
triangles into groups and then you can
build up a tree structure but this tree
structure now and depends and the
triangles so the fundamental unit there
is a triangle not a subspace of your
whole scene William so now they have
advantages and disadvantages otherwise
you would only take the pattern
so Katie trees they are usually faster
for traversal on the CPU here I mean our
multi-core CPUs but they have usually a
larger amount of nodes and they have
duplicate references because if we go
back to this example here we have points
okay a point Kim does not have a spatial
extent but if you imagine that you have
triangles and you cut through the whole
volume then it could be that you cut
through triangles and then you have two
possibilities either you just add the
triangle to both volumes so you get
dublicate references that means your
triangle discard is less efficient
because you have to check against this
triangle if you're in the left or in the
right path or you cut the triangle
itself and add 1/2 year 1/2 year but
cutting a lot of scene content is
computationally expensive so this would
tend to create the performance of the KD
tree generation bounding volume
hierarchies are very popular for GPUs
and multi-core architectures so the
scene file for example so they got more
attention in the in recent research
because it is because most of the
current work tried to implement
so the spatial hierarchy generation on
GPUs or other highly parallel
architectures they are also easier to
update because imagine you have a moving
object inside your seen a key d3 cuts
the whole volume apart and then if you
have object moving from one sub volume
to another you would have to update the
whole key t3 because you don't really
have a grasp on at which level you have
to edit it bounding volume hierarchies
on the other side the group objects
together so there you can just you have
the option of ignoring dynamic
complication because say you have to
object and B that are close together so
you generate your bounding volume
hierarchy so they are grouped together
at some level of the tree and if they
then move apart the grouping is not
influenced the only thing that happens
is that the bounding volume that holds
both groups gets larger and larger so
what happens is that your spatial
hierarchy gets more inefficient because
say a lot of empty space is generated in
between object a and B so three-race the
travel exactly through this gap between
them they would still have to check a
and B if you would then update your
bounding volume hierarchy to acknowledge
that they are spatially separated then
they would be cut at a they would be put
into different branches of the tree at a
different level but you don't have to do
that so in bounding volume hierarchies
dynamic seems just degrade your
performance at don't invalidate your
whole hierarchy because in KT trees if
you move from one SAP volume to the
other you have to update this in the
whole tree and this put
quite complicated because traversing the
tree for highly dynamic scene can be
very costly I mean you and another
advantage for bounding volume
hierarchies is that they are that every
object is only in one tree leaf I mean
this is naturally because it's
constructed that way but a negative
point of them are that the nodes can
spatially overlap so if you put two
triangles that are close by other in two
different nodes of the bounding volume
hierarchy then you still generate the
box around them to do a fast
intersection test but if those triangles
are say see right next to each other
then a simple box will have some overlap
so the bounding volume hierarchy can be
inefficient if you generate a lot of
boxes with content in it that overlap to
a large extent